I want you to figure out science for a
minute and that particular science up
like you define is chemistry now does
anyone know what chemistry is the
science of physics is the science of
moving object what's the chemistry the
science of McCullar very good so it's
like stuff like what is stuff made of
that's chemicals and how to stuff like
interact with each other that's chemical
reactions okay yes yeah very good sir
we then learn a whole bunch of different
terminology about chemistry and I'm
going to call your mind back to two of
them okay you may or may not admit them
but I'm going to quickly explain you
know what they are even if you don't
know the word so in chemistry we have
when we talked about chemicals and stuff
right there are two really important
categories of stuff the two categories
are I need some colors elements and when
you put a whole bunch of elements
together you get see maybe have a
minister it's okay I'm gonna appease -
yeah elements and compounds okay now if
you have not met these words before
that's fine I think we know what all of
these actually are you know a whole
bunch of examples let me write some for
you so elements are things like oxygen
or carbon so we've heard all these words
before even if we're not super familiar
and don't know a whole lot about them
just yet I promise you will it's really
exciting to learn about those things and
what they do these are things that we
call elements they're all on the
periodic table everything on the
periodic table is one of these but if
you take some of these and combine them
together you get things caught compounds
okay so um compounds that we're very
familiar I feels like water what is a
compound of so many elements that I've
already actually written on the board
does anyone know which elements they are
they're quite famous yeah
very good weave write it as H two O two
hydrogen's and an oxygen you sort of
wear them together you get a big fat
molecule and we call that thing that
whole thing we call it water right now
there's lots of other kinds of compounds
like that some that are you're very
familiar for example when you're cooking
and you go reach for the count on you
get the table salt you pour out all that
white grainy stuff right it is a
compound of two elements anyone know
what the two elements one has it's going
right down I'll write down what the two
and over time you will learn once about
these later it's not my main point today
the two elements are sodium and chloride
sodium has na there's a reason for that
there's a story behind every element
that's made and it's simple but I my
point is that table salt just a stuff
makes it a spoon it's made up on some of
these things okay there's one last
common example that I don't talk about
which is that the stuff that we breathe
in is mostly oxygen nitrogen few other
things but up above where we are like
way way above there's a particular layer
of a compound which protects us from UV
radiation they don't know what that
layer is called it around the entire
start of an ode yeah it's a compound
it's what happens when you take not one
not two but three oxygens and your weigh
them together so could it's three we
right Oh three okay
I should write dot dot because there's
lots more compounds and there are lots
of my elements okay
so let me just review this idea that
this is the stuff that these universally
made off okay and you can put together
this stuff in different ways you can
combine them a bit like Lego you can fit
it together in different configurations
themselves as in chemistry in
mathematics we have a similar kind of
idea that the stuff of mathematic
is well it's not only but a lot of it is
numbers right we do lots of work with
numbers okay and we talk about just like
stuff right we're talking about two
categories and numbers and here that you
category my two colors are the two
carries are called lines and this name
sounds very similar to the name we just
wrote down if they're not primes they're
called compasses now I'm drawing this
parallel and I'm showing it in the
colors in for a very good reason
okay so priming our numbers and I'm
gonna write down the staff dimension in
a second but we used two examples first
find some numbers that are hard to split
up okay do you remember yesterday we're
going through the diagnosis test right
do you remember we talked about a class
with 31 students in it do you remember
that yeah 31 students now 31 is a prime
number because you can't divide it up
into groups nearly always there's
something left over remember we divided
into fires
there's a guy left everybody find two
threes by left over and so on and so on
yes the whole thing together okay if
it's on the board commendable so 31 is
what clubs prime number because when you
divide it you always get something left
over you always get a remainder
okay so prime numbers that you might be
more familiar if you look at the small
ones they aren't the first four Prime's
are two three five and seven right these
are numbers where if you're um if you're
trying to divide up into even teams you
know two teams or three teams or four
teams if you have these numbers you're
kind of stuck right like you can't
divide it up into you hum a nicely you
always get some kind of remainder okay
compass it's on the up hand you can
divide up right you can get them into a
whole bunch of team in group so I'll
just give you the first few composite
numbers on the first we are four six
eight
10 and they go on from there okay now
the important thing is in exactly the
same way that I can write a compound in
terms of which elements are written you
see that it's like the best compound
it's made up of two hydrogen's and an
oxygen there's another three oxygen for
every composite number you can write the
primes that go in that's how you know
that it's going to be a composite and
not a crime for instance if I tried to
take four I could divide that up into a
couple of groups right it would be two
times two do you agree with that so this
is kind of like the equivalent of this
these are the prime numbers that make up
for okay
I'm six now what prime numbers go in to
six three three and okay I could do for
right but four is not a prime number is
it I can go further than four what's a
little smaller than 4 that can divide
into there yeah you cubed okay I can do
two then I can do two and then I could
do it again it's 2 times 2 times 2 so
this is a little bit like this is kinda
like hos or you see it's like three
oxygens together will give you a zone
three twos together will give you eight
and I can keep going okay question yeah
sure if it's on the boy Jeanine you look
now rather than just go by a table I
want to give you a rule that kind of
encapsulates all this together rules are
not because we want to give you lots of
things to memorize but because it's a
pattern here and if you understand what
the pattern is it's a lot quicker so
crimes are numbers we've exactly fact it
right what's a factor these are factors
these things here numbers you can divide
by right so these are numbers which I
can divide by two and is for example -
okay / - what's the other number I can
it's fun yeah maybe I'm trying to divide
- I want numbers that are smaller than
that right Christian what your every one
I can divide this by two could divide it
by 1/3 what can I do my that by you can
divide by ya three eight one five and
one seven one you started getting the
the package right so I'm looking for
exactly two factors for composites these
are numbers not with two factors but
with more factors right numbers with
more than two so for example going back
to four right what numbers can I divide
4 by it's not just one and four I can
divide by two so it's got three factors
how about six we did this in a
diagnostic what are the factors of six
you can divide by 3/2 and then of course
one and six I've got four factors do you
see that so if I can divide by more than
two I'll get a composite that's right
however I haven't written down as my
definition for this whole thing because
there's one guy which you might notice
is kind of a bit lonely and not included
in this at all
there's a single number that doesn't
have two factors and it doesn't have
more than two factors in fact it has
less than two factors and it's only one
of him they don't know what it is yeah
now see it's like okay I can't divide
one by anything except for itself it
does have two doesn't have more than two
so one one has only one factor right so
it's for the only one I suppose this one
says it is neither prime nor composite
it's neither of those okay so it is
prime nor composite so of the numbers
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten cetera all the way off to
infinity you've got one which is kind of
this special reader and then everything
else is either prime or composite just
like I love stuff in the world is either
an element or compound fantastic so now
we're going to start by understanding
the stuff that we can do with these
numbers primes encompasses is amazing
this is just the beginning
so our heading is Prime's and comma six
and if you open up to the exercise the
first thing we want to do is just be
able to sort out what is the number is
it prime or is it composite okay true
it's a bit Mary and then you read that
way and one has only one factor so it is
neither prime nor composite